what's more important for an actor build
their resume or their IMDB page IMDB is
your resume it's it's everything IMDB is
where people go to see whether you've
been working who you've worked with if
you don't have a lot of credits on your
imbd page and some of them are not in
red showing that they're in
pre-production or filming are just in
post then you're not considered to be
working it doesn't matter what your
resume says because people don't have
time anymore to do anything other than
give you a 20 second Google and the
first thing is going to come up is your
imbd so I'm a big believer in pimping
out your imbd page put your tweets on
there put your blog posts on there try
to get comments on there you want it to
look full and rich because I may be
wrong but I think that's an actor's web
page today that is our website what
about your bio how long do you make it
there's some people that I mean they
have a dissertation written and then
there's others that's just a quick thing
what do you think it's the best approach
to here's my little imbd bio a trick
when you google yourself look and the
first sentence and a half roughly of
your IBD bio show in the extract on the
Google page so that first sentence and a
half is crucial because many times
people won't even click to the imbd
they're just seeing who you are and that
bio should tell exactly who you are
don't waste that first sentence and a
half with he was born in Kansas and he
likes puppies nobody cares nobody cares
so when I started out my bio said Bill
Oberst juniors an American actor known
for disturbing on-screen presence I
wasn't I am now but I wasn't but I said
I was and it became true it's very very
important now I've switched it to Bill
oversteers the face of the Emmy
award-winning application from Jason
Zanna take this lollipop and then the
rest so that way even if they never go
deeper into the bio they get that
extract on the Google page so if someone
doesn't have the experience they would
like should they write something that's
almost a self-fulfilling prophecy yes
self-fulfilling prophecy you were so
right that's very very smart of you to
say that perception is reality my
manager Matt Jason says this to me all
the time
perception is reality in this business
it's not a joke it's true what you want
to be known for say that you already are
known for it and it helps people
categorize you because it's really
important in LA to have casting
directors know what you're known for and
it helps them do their job
you